let's go to everyone's favorite or least
favorite part of the week nobody is in
the middle on these uh hearing from the
audience segments people either love it
or they hate it and they threaten to
leave all the time
um I want to hear from some of the most
important people to us the viewers
because otherwise I'm a guy in a room
with a microphone and some lights and it
would be really sad we take calls on
Fridays via Discord you can find the
Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord let's start today with Mark from
San Antonio Texas Mark welcome to the
program what can I do for you today
am I unmuted you are unmuted and coming
through loud and clear sir
great uh thanks for taking my call again
David
um I'm I don't know if you saw yesterday
but uh Carey Lake again had her lawsuit
tossed out and I'm just starting to
think more and more that unlike you know
Marjory Taylor green and and
Mike pillow I don't think she's a firm
believer I think she's just nothing but
a grift and I wondered your take on it
with with each subsequent you know uh
appearance she makes on media it just
seems more and more like she's just a
really polished news person that's
giving you know a polished performance
uh however horrifying that might be I
tend to agree with you and one of the
comments I made earlier this week was
if she had been unable to grift any
money with this stuff starting in
November she would have stopped by now
the reason that it continues is people
keep donating and now even though it's
it's being called the last ditch that
was now thrown out
she's now saying she's going to try to
get it to the Supreme Court and she even
said you can still keep donating even
though I'm not here asking for money you
can keep donating I believe that with
Kerry Lake it is a grift I don't think
she believes any of it for a second she
knows Katie Hobbs won maybe she believes
some element of how the election was run
was unfair but the idea that she's
continuing to fight to be made the
governor it's like that's not how it
works it's not going to happen I agree
with you that Carrie lake is a grifter
yeah it's just it's it's performance art
at this point and I think you know if
somebody uh on the left were willing to
you know go that far to create a
performance you know a character and
then suddenly flip the script and oh by
the way I'm Progressive I think you know
the right would meet it would absolutely
explode but here they've just platformed
her for forever uh when I'm sure she's
probably somewhere in the middle or
moderately conservative but this is you
know it's just Insanity it's performance
yeah I remember like I don't want to
misspeak but didn't she support Obama at
one point
yes yeah that's uh security Lake
supported Obama uh yeah Obama backing
Arizona news anchor became a Maga
darling yep well it is what it is listen
how is that San Antonio Riverwalk I've
never been
you know um it used to be just firmly
for tourists and then you know there was
a bunch of money committed to extending
the the River Reach and there's only
like one last section left but you'll be
able to go from the museums
um all the way to the very
um tip you know very southern tip of it
to the the final mission the UNESCO
Mission Heritage sites so you know sure
the Riverwalk downtown is just nothing
but restaurants and hotels but once you
get outside of that you can rent a bike
and ride all the way to the to the
Spanish missions and it's it's a good
time it's it's really pretty I'm gonna
have to get down there Mark I appreciate
the call
all right thanks David all right there
it goes mark from San Antonio Texas why
don't we go next
to Bentley from Utah Bentley welcome to
the program
hello can you hear me yes I can
all right perfect
um so I've just been looking into some
other countries like Denmark lately and
I was wondering if you would ever
consider moving to a country that is
more like
socially Democratic you know listen I
would consider it the the thing for me
about uh you know Denmark would be an
easy one to go I speak English and
Spanish and Denmark would be easy
because everybody speaks English in
Denmark or most people do I've been
there it's a fantastic country the
cuisine was great the people were
delightful expensive expensive country
for sure in really practical terms I I'm
not seriously considering moving other
than I would and I plan to especially
for my daughter to get Spanish Immersion
I do plan to spend extended periods of
time in Argentina and I've actually done
so recently like with not not with big
Fanfare but there have been periods
where I've produced the show from
Argentina
um but moving you know it circumstances
would have to be very extenuating for me
to move because the reality is a bunch
of my family is in the United States my
job is in the United States a lot of my
friends and you know this sort of thing
so Denmark is a place if if I were
looking to move Denmark would be a great
place to move to I'm just not actively
looking right now
yeah fair enough
thanks for taking my call all right
Bentley from Utah great to hear from you
very much appreciate that let's go to uh
is it Phineas let's go to Phineas from
is it Kentucky something with a K I'm
not sure
Phineas please unmute yourself so we can
hear what your name is and where you're
going oh Kansas Phineas from Kansas yes
sorry uh Phineas from Kansas hi David
thanks for having me on I was calling to
ask in 2010 the Supreme Court overturned
Citizens United and if you look at voter
participation before 2010 it actually
shows a decrease in in voter
participation and volume and numbers
um and ever since then we've seen a
growth in these numbers I was just
wondering if you believe that as opposed
to
supporting a party The increased
spending in elections has merely just
increased voter participation which
could potentially backbite against
Republicans and have an advantage for
Democrats well hold on a second you said
in 2010 the Supreme Court overturned
citizens united that's a that's a the
phrasing is is relevant here because my
understanding is I'm sorry in 2010 yeah
the Supreme Court
okay in 2010 the Supreme Court
reversed an earlier decision by a lower
court which upheld that the first
amendment applies to campaign Finance
laws and uncapped a lot of different
types of spending we're on the same page
on that right
yes yeah you're arguing that after that
happened
we've actually seen voter participation
increase which isn't good for
Republicans so it sounds like what
you're saying is in some underhanded way
might the citizens united decision of
2010 actually have been a bad thing for
Republicans am I understanding correctly
that is correct I think the difficulty
of that argument is that correlation is
different than causation we would have
to demonstrate that political turnout
increased because of that decision and
I've not seen any evidence that that's
the case
okay well I appreciate your time thank
you all right Phineas from Kansas a
perfectly reasonable question I must say